i managed to grab a few uh frenetic
words with him
in the uh the bustle of those crowds and
he told me that
this country has a lot to do if it's to
get back on its feet again
but what can the european community do
sky news to help
to help to help as happily as we can we
brought
drugs direct ads
sergers doctors we have to send food
they need materials to build now their
location
but you see his attention people are
very nervous against our politicians
so at the same time we build this
emergency head
we need a new political initiative and
i'm here
to bring help to help to coordinate we
will launch a european and international
initiative
to bring money and help directly to
people
but at the other side we have to launch
a new political initiative
to change in depth what is today at sake
because
all this diversity that you see
all this this fear that's anxiety
and anger you have is against
politicians
and against corruption in the country
everything is broken
a lot of things but you know in this
country you have marvelous people
lebanese peoples i'm so brave
[Applause]
alex amazing stuff everything is broken
uh your question to which
he certainly didn't demure did he and
the important thing right now i suppose
is to get the port back up and
functioning
as quickly as possible get the food
coming in in in
real volume
and that's right those are the initial
kind of
focus of the emergency response but when
you go back to that question about
everything that's broken and this is
i suppose one of the incredible things
about this disaster
huge explosion here it would knock any a
nation
off its feet having to deal with that in
its uh capital city